tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigeva gli sono andati su the
sims come avevo promesso ragazzi
nell'ultimo episodio ho messo sasha
sabrina seppe fare davanti a casa mia
pietro ancora non l'ho messo ma
semplicemente perché ciò una ragazza che
con la quale c'è qualche inciucio e
vedere come va a finire
mi stava dicendo ragazzi come avevo
appunto promesso che oggi proverò a
interagire con i ragazzi che mi vivono
nella porta che sono i miei dirimpettai
che tra l'altro hanno addobbato casa
perché i ragazzi non è stato fatto caso
allora il problema è il natale ci sono
step e fare una festa dell'amore la
possono fare uno stage e sabrina che la
festa dell'amore lo possono fare e poi
ci sono io col cane ecco ciao samp
buongiorno già perché sono sveglio alle
mezzogiorno o e la sera
cosa stai facendo venir fuori che piove
i bagni buon casinò non pisciare de fori
ma non mi caga stato a cag ato a spruzzo
perché la cacca è andata tipo metro più
avanti vpro sun fai schifo ma posso mai
avere un cane così tu la smetti di farti
panini di fuori piove per l'amor di dio
federica il mio gino dice che il
festival dell'idillio è un buon posto
per fare le conoscenza bene e porta con
te degli amici
io non ho amici ripari conoscenza perché
lo faccio schifo sulla persona sociale
va bene allora facciamo così viviamo se
becco state fair e oss aprire sasha lì
se non li mcauley mi godo il festival e
poi torno a casa e carino il festival
dell'idillio
maledizione ma stai preferì stanno
veramente incastrati in casa non fanno
niente l'ho sospeso 21 spegne i soldi ma
cosa compri trink poi riprendi drink per
il tuo amico omar sta facendo resta
questa è pazza vabbè senti zio mafai
amicizia un attimo presentazione
scortese mandato a cagare e torna a casa
ok c'è già non gliene fregava niente
incontrare le persone uno su due è brava
a far amicizia della barista
presentazione michevole ora che marpione
guarda che achievement ho incontrato
delle persone con tasti federica sta
ballando da sola li peng e allora io
credo che federica secondo me e mi
invita tutte le feste sperando che io
alla approcci per un po io me ne vado
sempre sempre in tutte le feste me ne
vado e lei si ritrova a ballare da sola
un po come la mongoloide io e io non lo
riesco a farci niente perché sono league
e che non la call call me ne torno a
casa senti zio non ci sono state fair e
come pensavo quindi torniamo a casa
lasciamo federica ii così dorna che no
no no ti prego ti prego non ti prego no
ti prego ragazzi aiuto ragazzi aiuto c'è
un problema
ho iniziato a cantare speriamo che
nessuno a proposito altro che triste da
solo sto cantando da un c'è nessuno
anche l'unico che c'era sta andando
perfetto a noi data lui venuto qua forse
per insultarmi visto abbiamo litigato no
non c'è nessuno sono io che cantò da
solo che ho la voce di elvis presley
però
ragazzi possiamo andare a casa che sta
diventato tutto molto kringe canta in
duetto country con veronica salava la
barista mela me la faccio con la barista
ma no ragazze high school musical non
può piacere perché è in corso un evento
sociale ma non lo voglio fare
l'industriale smetti di cantare vasta è
una cosa khrin gissi ma vai via
cosa vuol dire in corso un evento
sociale non posso tornare a casa durante
gli eventi sociali
niente o sono proprio innamorato della
barista non ci posso fare nulla continua
a parlarci ma come sono stanco morto vai
zio torna a casa
marlene torna a casa prossimo
personaggio chiamo marley non per andare
alle feste tornare a casa e basta va
bene e vai a dormire e domani video
mostra che fa veramente mi sono rotto le
balle non li becco mai da nessuna parte
io che ci provo
vai a dormire zio a dormire ei hai
davvero buon gusto vieni al mercato
delle pulci per aiutarmi comprare
qualcosa con cui ravvivare un po casa
mia zia mi spiace andiamo a vedere
sabrina e sasha come se la passano let's
go
no perché se non vado io questi non
escono mamma mia ragazzi un po di vita
eccoli ragazzi allora viva allora
esistete non siete solo segregati in
casa che è successa cha cha cha e
bagnato perché a sta piovendo ho portato
anche same così può giocare con i cani
con sacco a sabrina presentazione
amichevole mi devo presentato sapeva
perché non ci conosciamo ancora la cia
che gioca con samsung some che ringhia
sasha che è figo allegra ragazze
bellissimo e bellissimo far combaciare
le persone ma finalmente finalmente such
a non suicidarsi per strada la sto
facendo
sono stupido l'assassino come stai
ho già un po ci sono ecco forse sasha
quello che di profilo ci somiglia di
meno sabrina è uguale chiacchiera dei
valori della proprietà per chiedergli
soldi con youtube non soprende mina
aereo e io posso prendermi gli alieni
pensate stage aperto l'ombrello ed entra
in casa questa cosa non è proprio
normale però dunque non volevo dirlo ma
esaurite gatti puzzano
sta puzzando il gas che tanto non sapevo
come si chiamava negativi sabrina lo
chiamati tutti tipo questo è il gatto
bello questo è se stai fermo io sto
parlando di pesci con sabrina same
rincorre la gente sa cosa stai pensando
sun sun dove i ca san salvi sta
scappando il cane zio il cane fa buche
per strada non so se norma sasha sabrina
vi ho fatto bucay giardino fa niente più
delicati sta chiedendo se vuoi andare a
casa sua per passare tempo assieme
vecchia marpiona ma perché non possiamo
semplicemente tipo che ne so entrare in
casa visto che fuori piove
lorenzo ha scoperto i seguenti tratti
disabili in avanti dei cani non si
capiva che sto facendo
riempi di gavettoni cosa nel pd cavetto
che si disputa la lotta di gavettoni con
sabrina
ma perché ci stiamo lanciando veramente
i gavettoni e sabrina ma io non ci credo
comunque siamo veramente noi e vi giuro
che io e sabrina faremo veramente questa
cosa poi chi sei valore sono veramente
scarso o sto per andare incontrai steve
fair e finalmente ci siamo ragazzi come
state
tutto bene bussa alla porta cosa busso
che sono fuori però ragazzi potete anche
vivere presentazione amichevole chastel
sebbene mamma mia ragazzi stesse uguale
digiuno stesso fatto veramente uguale
ora che roba anche fare un pochettino
verrai più o meno per per essere the
sims sono bravo dai set è molto più alto
in realtà però non puoi modificare
l'altezza almeno io non l'ho visto però
raga dai ci somigliano sono stato bravo
e comunque o chi è questa summer holiday
ma chi sei
chi è questa qua ad un'uscita è una
gnocca paura tra l'altro un regalo a
prima su un regalo tratto un regalo per
terra i miei occhi prende trova si trova
prendere a terra contrario ho trovato
qualcosa che non ho capito ma dovevi
sempre gas a me sembra ascoltare la
conversazione con un sacco di gioia
finalmente ragazzi e ho fatto amicizia
con tutti era logico messo una vita ma
finalmente un episodio dove parlo con
tutti i miei amici ovviamente questa
quota alice de luca fa vedere come
greene alice per imparare a camminare
almeno quello mamma mia ragazzi se era
abbordabile la zia peccato come come
cammini prove ove con questo fisico da
sollevatore di polemiche ti voglio
abbordare scusami
cosi facendo amico mio quanto gay un po
meno c'è nel senso che chi devi fare il
bagno nel fango a parti che dove l'hai
preso il fango ma non metterci non
metterti cetrioli per l'amor di dio ti
prego che schifo comunque cazzi se avete
notato non è più venuto il vampiro a
rompermi le balle perchè con lui mi
aveva giurato di tornare a succhiarmi
sangue quel maledetto che questa la
posta di oggi è stata consegnata ma che
è alice de luca la postina di prima era
la postina presentazione possediamo sia
fuori che l'amica e credibile la postina
perché non ho mai avuto una postina così
ignota ma la mia postina e così le
bollette sono però state recapitate devi
pagare 3000 alice e poi non portarmi le
bollette per favore ok sta facendo
amicizia lamentati dalle bollette altre
scelte bufo bufo fa il bufo bufo a nora
dopo più andare ok ok ok niente con una
volta ragazzi mi è capitato nella vita
di non pagare una bolletta che non
sapevo che dovevo pagare io penso fosse
compresa nella casa no niente ma non
staccato internet è stato orribile
il festival e distrarsi in città clicca
su una delle
dinamica in giro per la città per
saperne di più ecco io continuo a
guadagnare 224 dollari nei giorni liberi
che lavoro faccio scusa ma lo youtuber è
veramente che non fai niente guadagni
soldi ha già è vero che illumina il
cielo buio diabolico riflessioni
disasters andiamo andiamo con tutti ci
siamo
buongiorno la sfida tra burroni
mattacchioni iniziato inizia vivendo il
tè scuro quello chiaro per schierarti io
bere il tè chiaro immagino pur code
voglio che kakà ragazzi ma ed è
fighissimo
ok che se in solitario va bene che è una
vita che fa schifo io lo so io lo so
però ti prego vai a vedere i fuochi
d'artificio spegnifuoco l'artificio
rovina la festa agli altri dai fai
qualcosa di udine fa dovette chiaro
school eccolo world heal the chiaro e
mattacchioni io sono un mattacchione
preferisco sono mattacchione che burlone
via via via hanno bevuto il tè roma non
ha fatto bene ha fatto scomparire prima
e l'ho preso lo stesso e chi se ne frega
l'ho preso e mi sono schierato prenditi
devil te o mi sono seduto cosa sta
facendo la stesse per e stanno
discutendo e io mi siedo tra di loro
giustamente di cos'è che stiamo
rifiutava tanto stiamo mangiando anche
se possono una scacchiera west ha
pensato una famiglia di abitare parliamo
gli stessi io ragazzi non capisco mi
spiegate per quale arcano motivo in
questo festival scompaiono le cose qual
è il motivo perché il festival dei
burloni allora scompare la loro la roba
anche la gente siamo rimasti solo noi
schaefer e che maneggia al telefono e
gli altri che si discutono tra di loro
va beh io torno a casa
ciao ragazzi è stato bello giocare con
voi i ragazzi spray vi sia piaciuto come
se sì vi è piaciuto
argomento mi piace ancora di sociale
quindi iniziare piaciute anche la
campanella vicino al tasso iscriviti per
ricevere le notifiche sono i video era
come sempre ci rivediamo a un prossimo
video della ragazzi
[Musica]